well that didn't take long Democrats are
now demanding a new wave of
investigations into President Trump
it comes after senior DOJ officials
overruled a sentencing recommendation to
Sen Roger stone to jail for up to nine
years for the prosecutors on the case
quit and protests and Democrats claim
Trump interfered by tweeting about it
but the Justice Department says the
decision was made before Trump took to
Twitter and the mainstream media of
course is losing it this is what a
banana republic does this is what a
dictator does if you related to Trump
but you're a friend of Trump go out and
rob a bank because he's got you covered
it's preposterous to think that the
president's own public statements had no
impact I've never seen it happen in my
entire career what Donald Trump not do
whatever he could do if he could get
away with it seriously if he could
arrest every journalist he didn't like
do you think he would arrest us tomorrow
if you say he wouldn't you're just lying
to yourself president Trump's fired up
and he's hitting back the fact is that
Roger stone was treated horribly and so
were many of the people their lives were
destroyed I want to thank the Justice
Department they saw the horribleness of
a nine year sentence for doing nothing
you have murderers and drug addicts
it'll get nine years in the meantime
Comey walks around making book deals the
people that launched the scam
investigation and what they did is a
disgrace all right one you want to see
Roger stone die in prison
Oh nine years is the death sentence for
someone like that I was there right yeah
he's like 70 years old I don't know that
I mean here would be for me a week Greg
I might enjoy it
you never know we'd have to go anywhere
no red line there no red whoa wait a
second and they have ribs all right so
anyway I just think you have four career
prosecutors decide to resign I don't
think there's any question something bad
is going on here with regard to a pillar
of our great American Constitution which
is that we are a nation of laws I agree
and suddenly you have the president the
pregnant you know what struck me today I
remember when this president
got upset because Bill Clinton met with
Loretta Lynch on a tarmac and he said oh
my god
he's he was influencing the Attorney
General to do his bidding with regard to
Hillary in the email
now here comes president Trump and he is
clearly expressing his views in a way
that will influence the Attorney General
Bill Barr to come out and say oh yeah
you know what these prosecutors of mine
they've overdone it but Jesse that's
that's corruption this is the president
can't express his views on Twitter I
guess that's another impeachable offense
Wow
well I evade some phone calls today to
try and clarify what's going on at the
Justice Department and how this whole
thing went down because the timeline
here is very important so the DOJ was in
contact with the new US attorney Tim
Shea for a week about this understanding
that the prosecutors would go to the
judge and say we are going to recommend
less than seven to nine years seven to
nine is too harsh but we're not going to
say a number they go in they roll over
the US Attorney in DC the first week on
the job and they put the sentencing in
with seven to nine years Barr finds out
about it it's a total disaster and they
say well now we have to change it
because it's not fair and it doesn't
actually match what went down with the
trial so that decision was made there
was an understanding for a week before
this happened then President Trump
decides to go on Twitter and discuss it
which has created all of this this
backlash about did he have influence but
they've been talking about this and the
US Attorney's office in DC has been
working with the Department of Justice
for more than a week on this
understanding that this kind of filing
and the sentencing would be less or at
least not 79 years for Roger stone and
the US Attorney's Office essentially
blew it and now you have these Moeller
investigations or prosecutors saying
we're out but I think the reasons why
and the timeline is getting a little bit
mixed up with people are talking about
it Greg what do you think I am no longer
going to give the media or the Democrats
any advice I'm no longer to tell them
the smart thing to do because I did that
with obstruction and collusion in
Kavanaugh and impeachment they ignore it
so I'm gonna say to the media I'm gonna
say the Morning Joe and CNN chase this
story go for it how about it this is
what's gonna win
Eric in mind you getting some guy to die
in jail it's ironic that that Trump is
getting people out of prison and all the
Dems want to do is keep throwing people
back in but it's like this is all due to
that defective filter they have and they
keep seeing the view you watch the view
you just saw that clip they're in a
constant state of pain and Morning Joe
is in an endless hissy fit every morning
he wakes up he's in a hissy fit because
their filter is defective and they keep
seeing these things as it's the end of
the world you miss the big stories
Epstein right they miss Epstein they
miss Smollett they know they're ignoring
fence and all these screaming stories
but this is it
so I'm saying this is gonna win the
Pulitzer you guys got to chase this
story let's get Roger stone in jail for
life that's great go for it
yeah rapists I believe spend an average
four years in prison and this guy what
he's going to prison for nine years
because John Podesta fell for a phishing
email from a Russian witness tampering
is the one and the guy it said he was
supposedly intimidated says I wasn't
intimidated so I think what will end up
happening is the the US attorney the
assistant US Attorney's that resigned
they will also be investigated to see if
they were withholding information from
the US Attorney so now they are going to
have another six weeks or so because
bill Barr has agreed to testify in front
of the Congress on March 31st we've seen
how that's gone several times he just
runs rings around them and but that's
all happy March 31st no one will really
pay attention it is interesting that you
know the sentencing guidelines for
federal crimes there are they're due for
some revision and the president's been
willing to look at that the Democrats
actually applauded for that line in the
State of the Union but it when it comes
to something like Roger stone they want
the full sentence but wait until they
freak out when President Trump pardons
him you said this is a guy that was
witness tampering obstructing justice
live well and the guy in the trial who
they alleged witness tampering against
said that it was actually a joke and
they talk about stuff like that all the
time he actually did it they overcharged
on a hoax investigation to justify the
hoax it's fun living in a banana
republic isn't it guys